Est-ce qu'à tout hasard on en aurait pas un peu marre d'être con ?
Aujourd'hui les amis, on va élargir notre culture générale.
On va apprendre !
Incroyable !
Nous sommes sur "Vrai ou Faux".
Un jeu dans lequel on va nous donner des informations, et nous devons dire si c'est vrai ou faux.
C'est la première vidéo, de, euh, culture générale sur cette chaîne. *rire*
C'est parti !
"Le lac Baikal en Russie est le lac le plus profond du monde"
Pfou
Bah ça commence bien. Voilà !
Bouha, je, faux ?
Et non ! C'est vrai !
Vous pourrez dire à vos amis, que vous savez quel est le lac le plus profond du monde.
Bon bah écoutez, c'est reparti.
En vrai, j'ai vraiment envie de faire cette vidéo, parce que moi je manque beaucoup de culture générale.
Et ça m'énerve.
Du coup, j'espère qu'à la fin de cette vidéo j'aurai, la plus grande culture de France.
"Le mot "bookkeeper" est le seul mot anglais avec 3 doubles lettres consécutives."
Il pense... REGARDEZ SA TRONCHE!
Ouais.
Wouh !
Mon Dieu, merci le petit singe.
J'ai l'impression d'être intelligent grâce à toi.
"Une femme a portée plainte contre un hôpital en disant qu'un scanner lui avait fait perdre ses pouvoirs psychiques."
Appelez l'ambulance!!!
Nan mais ça c'est un truc qui devrais aller sur Jean-Marc-Morandini.com !
Ça va pas nous rendre plus intelligent de savoir ça ! *rire*
Écoute, ouais, ça ne m'étonnerait pas.
Bah voilà !
Merci Spi0n, pour toutes ces anecdotes incroyables.
"Dans l'anglais ancien, le mot "the" s'épelait "ye"".
#SQUEEZIE PENSE.. CHUT!!!
*rire*
Euuh. Non, j'pense c'est du Bull Shit. Vous nous prenez pour des cons.
*clap*
"La consommation de thé est supérieure à toutes les autres boissons combinées, incluant le chocolat
chaud, le café, l'alcool et les sodas."
Mec, n'importe quoi c'est faux c'est sûr !
Mais c'est sûr !
QUOI ?!
C'est pas possible !
Tu prends juste tous les fast-food de la planète
Les litres de soda qui sont consommés dedans
sont plus élevés aux litres de thé consommés n'importe où ailleurs !
Bon ok ok ok. Ok p'tit panda. T'as raison.
D'façon j'ai jamais aimé les pandas.
"Et je propose qu'on aille faire plein de câlins à ces pandas pour aller leur remonter le morale !"
"Le jeu "Guitar Hero" a rapporté plus d'argent à Aerosmith que n'importe lequel de leur albums".
Aaah !
Nan !
*rire* Ma réflexion elle était hyper courte !
Pfouu, non Aerosmith, quand même, ils ont vendus des palettes et des palettes !
C'est limite si à l'époque, t'achetait pas une canette de Coca t'avais un album d'Aerosmith avec !
D'un autre côté Guitar Hero le jeu, il est vendu 70 euros, un album c'est quoi, 15/20 euros ?
Moi j'pense que c'est vrai !
Allez, c'est vrai !
Whou !
P*tain c'est dingue ! Bien joué Aerosmith ! En même temps Guitar Hero ça défonce !
Bravo !
"A la naissance, un bébé pieuvre fait la taille d'un puce."
Une puce ? Non, j'pense que c'est fau-pffff.
Allez c'est vrai ? C'est la petite anecdotes qui te laisse sur le c*l ?
Et voilà !
C'est dingue ça ! La taille d'une puce carrément !
"Le film "Le Parrain" a été tourné à l'envers".
J'crois qu'c'est vrai...
*rire*
P*tain j'étais totalement serein en disant ça, là tous les mecs fan du cinéma ils vont m'insulter.
Y'a pas un film qui a été tourné à l'envers ?
Au pire, dites le moi dans les commentaires, ça me fera plein de commentaires, ma vidéo elle sera mise en avant par YouTube et j'aurai plein de vues.
Bon, ça c'est fait aloooors... *rire*
"Le Pringles Man a un nom, et il s'appelle "Julius"".
Voilà en ce moment je regarde la série "Pablo Escobar"  une série espagnole, et les "j" ça se dit *j avec un accent espagnol*".
Le "Pringles Man"... On parle donc de la mascotte qui n'intéresse absolument personne sur cette planète.
Ce gars là.
Julius ? Franchement avec sa moustache et sa coupe ? Moi j'dis ouais. moi j'dis ouais.
J'dis qu'c'est vrai.
Ben ouais ! Est-ce que ça nous étonnes ?
AC/DC a fait 21 musiques avec le mot "rock" dans le titre".
Vu le nombre d'albums qu'ils ont fait...
J'y crois. Vrai.
Whou !
*chante du AC/DC*
Il fut un temps j'étais leur troisième chanteur ouais.
"Moléculairement parlant, l'eau est beaucoup plus sèche que le sable.".
Ca c'était le genre d'anecdotes que j'adorais quand mon prof de Chimie me donne. Et il m'en donnait jamais d'ailleurs. *rire*
Quand un élément est sec, ça veut dire que y a peu de molécules ?
L'eau c'est H2O, le sable c'est, euh,
S4B ?
C'est vrai !
NAAAAAN !
Ça me semblait possible. Bon c'est le problème de ne pas avoir suivis les problèmes de chimie.
C'est que tu oublies ce que veut dire certains thèmes techniques.
"Tout ce qui reste de l'écriture de Shakespeare sont 6 signatures, et aucune d'entre elles ne s'épèles "Shakespeare"".
Franchement, ça m'étonnerait pas.
J'dirais qu'c'est vrai ouais.
Yeaaah !
Ça c'est bon à savoir ça !
Donc en fait on orthographies totalement mal le nom de ce mec. *rire*
"Les fleurs de vanille fleurissent pendant seulement 1 jour par année."
'tain, si ça se trouve c'est une anecdote trop obvious, que tous le monde sais déjà, tous vos parents l'ont déjà faites.
J'dirais quand même que c'est faux...
Ben Voilà. Merci papa, merci maman de ne jamais m'avoir fais cette anecdote.
Merci.
"61% des chats préfèrent écouter de l'opéra plutôt que de la K-POP".
WTF ? D'où ton chat il a des goûts musicaux ?!
Attends, Est-ce que ton chat est plutôt de ce style ?
*opéra*
Ou de ce style ?
*K-pop*
Je danse pareil hein.
*chante la chanson K-pop*
Moi j'pense que l'opéra ça les rends complétements oufs.
Donc, j'dirais qu'c'est faux du coup. J'dirais qu'ils préfèrent la K-pop.
Et bah voilà ! Et bah voilà !
Je l'savais !
"Au Mexique les artistes peuvent payer leur taxes en utilisant les artworks qu'ils ont fait".
Ah ouais ?!
J'pense que c'est faux, mais si c'est vrai c'est absolument génial donc je ne serais même pas déçu de m'être trompé.
J'suis pas déçu.
"Les tigres n'ont pas d'odorat".
Ah bon ?
C'est faux, c'est une c*nnerie ça c'est sur.
Pff. N'importe quoi !
"Yegor Letov a écrit son tube "Pro Durachka" en seulement une nuit avec 40 de fièvre."
*chanson de Yegor Letov*
C'est vrai.
C'est vrai et j'y crois totalement.
"En cas de mauvaise conduite, la punition d'un policier thaïlandais est de porter un brassare Hello Kitty."
Ça décrébilise un peu la police quand même ! *rire*
J'pense c'est faux c'est une c*nnerie.
C'est vrai ?!
Mais naaan !
Ça, ça va sur Jean-Marc-Morandi.com ça  !
"En Angleterre l'accent anglais est différent tous les 25 miles."
C'est comme nous, l'accent du Sud, Marseille, Toulouse, c'est pas le même. Eux c'est ça mais tous les 25 miles !
J'crois c'est vrai ! Il me semble que c'est vrai ça !
Ouais ! Ouais ouais ouais. Merci papa et maman de me l'avoir dit un jour.
"1 seul astéroïde peut contenir jusqu'à 20 milliards de dollars de métaux."
Ben ça dépends de sa taille ! Si il fait le double de la terre, ouais !
20 milliards ? Nan j'pense pas. Nan nan nan c'est faux j'pense.
( Journaliste : Les astronomes guettent le passage tout près de la Terre d'un énorme astéroïde cela doit se passer dans les minutes qui viennent...)
OH P*TAIN Y FAUT QUE J'Y AILLE MON POTE. J'PARTAGERAIS L'ASTÉROÏDE MONEY AVEC VOUS.
Et voilà les gens c'est déjà la fin de cette vidéo sur "Vrai ou Faux" ! J'espère que ça vous a plu !
Si c'est la cas, n'hésitez pas à l'aimer comme d'habitude, mais c'était quand même pas mal du tout !
On a appris pas mal de chose et ça fait plaisir ! Hein ?
Parce que d'habitude on apprends rien ! On fait les c*ns !
Si on fait une vidéo comme ça tous les mois pendant... 728 années...
Peut-être qu'on pourra gagner au "12 coups de midi".
Le Jean-Luc là, il sera sur le c*l.
Allez à très vite dans une prochaine vidéo, merci d'avoir regardé, portez vous bien, ciao tout le monde ...
peace.